selamat kembali ke Memahami Maklumat dan Pengiraan Kuantum nama saya John Watrous dan saya ialah
pengarah teknikal untuk pendidikan di IBM Quantum ini ialah pelajaran ke-11 dalam siri ini dan merupakan pelajaran ketiga dalam
unit ketiga yang berkaitan dengan formulasi umum maklumat kuantum pelajaran ini adalah tentang pengukuran yang mewakili
antaramuka antara maklumat Kuantum dan klasik apabila pengukuran dilakukan ke atas suatu sistem semasa ia berada dalam
Keadaan Kuantum maklumat klasik diekstrak mendedahkan sesuatu tentang Keadaan Kuantum tersebut dan secara umumnya mengubah atau
memusnahkan keadaan itu dalam prosesnya dalam formulasi mudah maklumat kuantum yang telah dibincangkan
dalam unit pertama siri ini kita biasanya mengehadkan perhatian kita kepada pengukuran projektif termasuk
jenis pengukuran paling mudah iaitu pengukuran asas piawai namun begitu adalah mungkin untuk menggeneralisasikan konsep pengukuran
dan itu rupanya merupakan perkara yang cukup berguna untuk dilakukan dalam pelajaran ini kita akan bincangkan pengukuran secara penuh
termasuk bagaimana ia dihuraikan dalam istilah matematik dan bagaimana ia sesuai dalam formulasi umum kuantum
maklumat menjelang akhir pelajaran kita juga akan melihat beberapa konsep asas yang berkaitan dengan pengukuran iaitu Diskriminasi Keadaan Kuantum
dan Tomografi Keadaan Kuantum jadi jom kita mulakan di sini adalah gambaran keseluruhan
pelajaran seperti yang selalu kita lakukan kita akan mulakan dengan asas-asas termasuk beberapa cara yang berbeza tetapi setara yang boleh kita
gunakan untuk menerangkan pengukuran dalam istilah matematik khususnya kita boleh menerangkan pengukuran melalui koleksi matriks
dan kita juga boleh menerangkannya sebagai saluran yang saya sentuh dalam pelajaran sebelumnya kita juga akan bincangkan
pengukuran separa atau dalam erti kata lain pengukuran yang dilakukan ke atas satu bahagian sahaja daripada sistem kompaun yang lebih besar
kemudian kita akan beralih kepada teorem Naimark yang merupakan fakta asas berkaitan pengukuran yang pada asasnya
menyatakan bahawa pengukuran Umum sentiasa boleh dilaksanakan dengan cara mudah yang mengingatkan kepada representasi Stein spring
bagi saluran ringkasnya pengukuran Umum sentiasa boleh dilaksanakan dengan terlebih dahulu memperkenalkan
sistem ruang kerja yang telah dimulakan kemudian menjalankan operasi unitari dan akhirnya menjalankan pengukuran asas piawai
ke atas sistem ruang kerja ini rupanya cukup mudah untuk dibuktikan dan kita akan lihat bagaimana ia berjalan dan
kita juga akan lihat bagaimana ini berkait dengan apa yang dipanggil pengukuran tidak-memusnah yang akan saya huraikan akhirnya di bahagian terakhir
pelajaran kita akan bincangkan Diskriminasi Keadaan Kuantum dan Tomografi Keadaan Kuantum kita akan mulakan dengan
penerangan matematik tentang pengukuran pengukuran memberi kita antaramuka antara maklumat Kuantum dan
klasik apabila pengukuran dilakukan ke atas sistem semasa ia berada dalam Keadaan Kuantum tertentu maklumat klasik
tentang Keadaan Kuantum itu diekstrak selain itu keadaan kuantum itu biasanya berubah atau mungkin
musnah sepenuhnya pada peringkat awal kita akan menumpukan perhatian kepada apa yang dipanggil pengukuran memusnah di mana
Keadaan Kuantum masuk dan hanya maklumat klasik yang keluar jadi tiada spesifikasi
keadaan kuantum selepas pengukuran bagi sistem yang telah diukur secara intuitif kita boleh bayangkan bahawa pengukuran memusnah
memusnahkan apa sahaja sistem yang diukur jadi keadaannya selepas pengukuran berlaku tidak
dinyatakan ini tidak bermaksud secara harfiah bahawa peranti fizikal semestinya musnah ia hanyalah
penerangan matematik dan ia sangat berguna kerana ia membantu memudahkan perkara dan menumpukan pada aspek
matematik penting bagi pengukuran terdapat khususnya dua cara setara untuk menerangkan pengukuran memusnah
yang saya sebutkan semasa gambaran keseluruhan pelajaran satu cara untuk menerangkan pengukuran memusnah
ialah melalui koleksi matriks di mana khususnya kita mempunyai satu matriks untuk setiap kemungkinan hasil pengukuran
cara kedua untuk menerangkan pengukuran memusnah ialah melalui saluran di mana
inputnya ialah keadaan apa sahaja sistem yang sedang diukur dan outputnya sentiasa merupakan matriks ketumpatan pepenjuru yang boleh kita
tafsirkan sebagai penerangan taburan kebarangkalian ke atas kemungkinan hasil pengukuran klasik
kedua-dua penerangan itu setara dan itu cukup berguna kerana membolehkan kita memilih mana-mana penerangan yang lebih mudah dalam
situasi tertentu kita juga akan bincangkan pengukuran tidak-memusnah di mana selain hasil pengukuran klasik
keadaan kuantum selepas pengukuran bagi sistem yang diukur juga
dinyatakan pengukuran tidak-memusnah adalah penting dan ia kerap timbul tetapi ada maksudnya di mana ia
tidak asas seperti pengukuran memusnah dalam istilah matematik khususnya rupanya
pengukuran tidak-memusnah sentiasa boleh diterangkan sebagai komposisi saluran dan pengukuran memusnah dan dengan
itu kita akan lihat cara kerjanya sedikit kemudian dalam pelajaran sekarang jom kita lihat bagaimana pengukuran iaitu pengukuran memusnah
boleh diterangkan sebagai koleksi matriks sepanjang perbincangan ini kita akan anggap bahawa X ialah sistem yang
sedang diukur dan demi kesederhanaan kita akan buat beberapa andaian pertama kita akan anggap bahawa
set keadaan klasik bagi X terdiri daripada integer dari 0 hingga n tolak satu untuk sesetengah integer positif n dan kemungkinan
hasil pengukuran ialah integer dari 0 hingga M tolak satu juga untuk sesetengah integer positif M tiada
keperluan untuk ada hubungan antara nombor n dan M kedua-duanya ialah integer positif yang sewenang-wenangnya dan tentunya kita boleh gantikan
set-set ini dengan set keadaan klasik yang sewenang-wenangnya jika kita mahu pertama jom kita imbas kembali cara kerja pengukuran projektif
yang kita bincangkan pertama kali dalam pelajaran ketiga siri ini memandangkan kita mengandaikan bahawa
hasil pengukuran ialah integer dari 0 hingga n tolak satu kita menerangkan pengukuran projektif melalui koleksi
unjuran Pi 0 hingga Pi M tolak satu yang berjumlah kepada matriks identiti dan matriks-matriks ini semuanya mempunyai baris dan
lajur yang sepadan dengan keadaan klasik X atau dalam erti kata lain semuanya adalah matriks n kali n
jika x berada dalam Keadaan Kuantum yang diterangkan oleh vektor Keadaan Kuantum s maka setiap kemungkinan hasil pengukuran
a muncul dengan kebarangkalian sama dengan norma Euclidean kuasa dua bagi Pi a didarabkan
dengan vektor s norma Euclidean kuasa dua bagi sebarang vektor sama dengan hasil darab dalam vektor itu
dengan dirinya sendiri jadi kita dapat ungkapan yang ditunjukkan di skrin dan kita boleh permudahkan sedikit
dengan menggunakan fakta bahawa Pi a ialah unjuran jadi mendarabnya dengan dirinya sendiri tidak
mengubah apa-apa dan akhirnya kita boleh tulis semula ungkapan yang diperoleh dengan cara yang sedikit berbeza menggunakan sifat kitaran
WEBVTT
dari surih sekali lagi seperti yang ditunjukkan di skrin dan jika tidak jelas kenapa kita mahu menulis ungkapan seperti ini
jawapan ringkasnya ialah kita ingin memahami bagaimana pengukuran projektif berfungsi untuk matriks ketumpatan
dan khususnya melalui kelinearan kita ada bahawa jika keadaan X diterangkan oleh matriks ketumpatan rho berbanding
vektor Keadaan Kuantum s maka kebarangkalian untuk hasil a muncul diberikan oleh surih unjuran
Pi a darab matriks ketumpatan rho itu mesti begitu kerana seperti yang kita lihat
kita sentiasa boleh fikirkan matriks ketumpatan sebagai purata berwajaran bagi keadaan tulen dan jika kita puratakan
kebarangkalian yang sepadan kita dapat ungkapan ini kerana surih ialah fungsi linear jadi itulah ungkapan yang kita
cari dan kita boleh kemas sedikit untuk menumpukan pada matriks ketumpatan
tujuan utama melakukan ini ngomong-ngomong ialah untuk menetapkan titik rujukan kepada apa yang sudah kita pelajari
dan untuk melihat bahawa penerangan pengukuran projektif ini sebenarnya merupakan kes khas penerangan lebih umum tentang pengukuran yang bakal
kita lihat jadi apa yang akan saya lakukan sekarang ialah menggantikan penerangan cara kerja pengukuran projektif untuk matriks ketumpatan
dengan penerangan untuk pengukuran Umum supaya kita boleh faham hubungan antara keduanya dan inilah
dia pengukuran umum yang tidak semestinya pengukuran projektif diterangkan oleh koleksi matriks semi-definitif positif
p 0 hingga PM tolak satu yang berjumlah kepada identiti dan jika pengukuran ini dilakukan ke atas X semasa ia
berada dalam keadaan yang diterangkan oleh matriks ketumpatan rho maka setiap hasil a muncul dengan kebarangkalian sama dengan surih PA darab
rho ringkasnya satu-satunya perkara yang berubah ialah kita telah melonggarkan syarat ke atas matriks-matriks ini khususnya matriks-matriks itu
tidak perlu menjadi matriks unjuran ia hanya perlu semi-definitif positif dan sebagai padanannya saya telah gantikan huruf Pi dengan huruf p
kerana Pi ialah nama konvensional untuk unjuran manakala saya suka menggunakan huruf P untuk matriks semi-definitif positif
ini ialah generalisasi penerangan yang kita ada untuk pengukuran projektif ngomong-ngomong kerana matriks unjuran sentiasa semi-definitif positif
dan sebenarnya ia boleh ditakrifkan secara alternatif sebagai matriks semi-definitif positif yang nilai-nilai eigennya
hanya boleh sifar dan satu kita boleh perhatikan bahawa takrifan ini
masuk akal kerana kita sentiasa mendapat vektor kebarangkalian untuk kebarangkalian hasil dengan cara berikut
pertama nombor-nombor yang saya rujuk sebagai kebarangkalian hasil sentiasa merupakan nombor nyata tidak negatif itu
kerana PA dan rho kedua-duanya semi-definitif positif dan surih hasil darab dua matriks semi-definitif positif
sentiasa merupakan nombor nyata tidak negatif dan saya serahkan kepada anda untuk fikirkan kenapa begitu
dan kedua nombor-nombor itu mesti berjumlah kepada satu kerana surih adalah linear
matriks p 0 hingga PN tolak satu diperlukan untuk berjumlah kepada identiti dan matriks ketumpatan mempunyai surih sama dengan
satu jadi tanpa mengira matriks ketumpatan rho yang kita mulakan dengannya kebarangkalian hasil memang sentiasa membentuk
vektor kebarangkalian sekarang jom kita lihat beberapa contoh saya sudah sebut bahawa
pengukuran projektif adalah kes khas pengukuran Umum kerana unjuran sentiasa semi-definitif positif
tapi bagus untuk bermula dengan yang mudah jadi jom kita mulakan dengan pengukuran asas piawai bagi sebuah qubit kita boleh wakili pengukuran asas piawai
bagi qubit dengan dua matriks p 0 dan P1 yang ditakrifkan seperti yang ditunjukkan di skrin p 0 ialah ket sifar bra sifar dan P1 ialah ket satu
bra satu kedua-duanya ialah matriks semi-definitif positif dan memang unjuran dan ia jelas berjumlah kepada
identiti jadi bersama-sama ia menerangkan pengukuran jika kita guna pengukuran ini pada qubit
dalam keadaan yang diterangkan oleh matriks ketumpatan rho maka kebarangkalian untuk hasil sifar muncul ialah surih p 0 darab rho
dan kebarangkalian untuk hasil satu ialah surih P1 darab rho dan menggunakan sifat kitaran surih kita dapat
dua entri pepenjuru rho seperti yang kita jangkakan ini pula satu lagi contoh di mana
kali ini matriks-matriks itu bukan unjuran ia memang semi-definitif positif dan ia kebetulan juga merupakan matriks ketumpatan
tapi itu tidak penting yang penting ialah ia berjumlah kepada identiti jadi bersama-sama ia menerangkan
pengukuran kita boleh lihat apa yang berlaku apabila pengukuran ini dilakukan ke atas qubit dalam keadaan plus misalnya
untuk melihat cara kerjanya dengan satu contoh keadaan dan pengiraan kebarangkalian ditunjukkan di
skrin perhatikan khususnya bahawa walaupun keadaan plus adalah keadaan tulen dan kita boleh wakili keadaan itu dengan vektor Keadaan Kuantum ket Plus kita memang
perlu masukkan representasi matriks ketumpatan bagi keadaan itu iaitu ket plus bra plus ke dalam formula untuk mendapat
kebarangkalian dan biar saya juga nyatakan bahawa kerana kita bercakap tentang pengukuran memusnah tiada sebarang
spesifikasi keadaan kuantum selepas pengukuran qubit ini jadi yang kita ada hanyalah spesifikasi
kebarangkalian hasil ini adalah contoh terakhir buat masa ini dan ia agak menarik sekali lagi ia adalah pengukuran
satu qubit dan untuk menerangkannya kita akan mulakan dengan mentakrifkan empat vektor Keadaan Kuantum yang dikenali sebagai keadaan-keadaan
tetrahedron sebabnya dipanggil keadaan-keadaan tetrahedron ialah kerana ia sepadan dengan empat bucu
tetrahedron sekata yang dilakarkan dalam sfera Bloch dan untuk jelaskan apabila kita kata ini ialah tetrahedron sekata
kita maksudkan pepejal empat sisi di mana setiap muka adalah segitiga sama sisi jadi ada simetri sempurna di sini setiap
tepi mempunyai panjang yang sama dan sudut yang sama terbentuk antara mana-mana dua tepi bersebelahan
dan sekarang kita boleh takrifkan pengukuran menarik dengan empat kemungkinan hasil seperti yang ditunjukkan di skrin atau dalam kata-kata kita boleh ambil
matriks-matriks kita sebagai representasi matriks ketumpatan bagi keadaan-keadaan ini dibahagi dengan dua kini ia memang
matriks semi-definitif positif kerana ia adalah matriks ketumpatan dibahagi dua dan anda boleh pergi melalui aritmetik untuk semak
bahawa ia memang berjumlah kepada identiti tapi cara lain untuk melihatnya ialah dengan fikirkan Simetri jika kita puratakan keempat-empat keadaan ini
bersama-sama kita dapat keadaan bercampur sepenuhnya yang berada di pusat sfera Bloch tapi kerana kita membahagi
masing-masing dengan dua berbanding empat kita dapat dua kali ganda keadaan bercampur sepenuhnya yang merupakan identiti saya tidak akan kata lebih tentang
pengukuran ini buat sekarang kecuali untuk perhatikan bahawa ia bukan pengukuran projektif tapi ia adalah contoh yang bagus dan
kita akan lihat ia muncul lagi kemudian dalam pelajaran cara lain untuk menerangkan pengukuran umum ialah sebagai saluran seperti yang akan
kita bincangkan sekarang idea di sini ialah keadaan kebarangkalian klasik boleh diwakili oleh matriks ketumpatan pepenjuru jadi
kerana hasil pengukuran adalah klasik kita boleh fikirkan tentang pengukuran sebagai saluran di mana outputnya sentiasa merupakan matriks ketumpatan pepenjuru
WEBVTT
matriks yang menerangkan hasil pengukuran jadi jom kita lihat ini dengan sedikit lebih terperinci jika kita fikir
secara abstrak tentang pengukuran umum kita boleh menerangkan pengukuran itu sebagai saluran fi sistem input untuk saluran itu ialah
apa sahaja sistem X yang sedang diukur dan sistem output ialah sistem y yang keadaan klasiknya sepadan dengan
hasil pengukuran yang kita ambil sebagai integer dari 0 hingga n tolak satu untuk sesetengah integer positif
M dan kerana hasil pengukuran adalah klasik kita memerlukan bahawa untuk setiap matriks ketumpatan input rho untuk sistem
X output fi rho mestilah matriks ketumpatan pepenjuru misalnya jika kita fikirkan
pengukuran asas piawai bagi qubit dan kita fikirkan pengukuran itu sebagai yang diterangkan oleh saluran kita boleh nyatakannya seperti yang ada di skrin
jika matriks ketumpatan input ialah rho maka kita akan dapat hasil sifar dengan kebarangkalian sama dengan bra sifar rho ket sifar
dan kita akan dapat hasil satu dengan kebarangkalian bra satu rho ket satu dan jika kita nyatakan
hasil pengukuran klasik ini sebagai matriks ketumpatan kita akan dapat ungkapan ini untuk Saluran yang sepadan dan rupanya
ia tiada lain ialah Saluran penyahfasa sepenuhnya dan itu bersesuaian dengan idea bahawa Saluran penyahfasa sepenuhnya
mewakili bentuk dekoheren yang ekstrem yang boleh bermaksud pelbagai perkara tapi apabila saya guna istilah itu saya
bercakap tentang kecenderungan Keadaan Kuantum untuk menjadi klasik kerana persekitaran di sekitar apa sahaja sistem yang kita
bicarakan sedang memerhati dalam suatu makna atau dalam erti kata lain ia sedang mengukur
jadi hasil pengukuran boleh diterangkan sebagai saluran seperti yang baru saya huraikan tapi ini bukan sekadar kemungkinan ia adalah
pencirian pengukuran Umum dan yang saya maksudkan ialah berikut tentunya ada saluran
yang tidak mewakili pengukuran kerana output mungkin tidak selalu menjadi matriks ketumpatan pepenjuru tapi jika memang
berlaku bahawa output saluran sentiasa merupakan matriks ketumpatan pepenjuru tanpa mengira keadaan input rho yang kita pilih maka ia semestinya boleh
dinyatakan sebagai saluran itu dalam bentuk yang ditunjukkan di skrin untuk sesetengah pilihan pengukuran iaitu koleksi
matriks semi-definitif positif yang berjumlah kepada identiti dan itu bagus atas pelbagai sebab termasuk fakta bahawa ia
pada asasnya memberitahu kita bahawa takrifan kita tentang pengukuran sebagai koleksi matriks tidak tercicir
sesuatu cara lain untuk menyatakan itu ialah cara memikirkan pengukuran sebagai saluran ini bersifat operasional
atau mungkin aksiomatik dalam erti kata bahawa ia menangkap apa yang pengukuran sepatutnya ada iaitu proses fizikal yang
mengubah maklumat Kuantum menjadi maklumat klasik dan rupanya ia sepenuhnya setara dengan penerangan pertama kita
tentang pengukuran yang bersifat algebra tulen saya tidak akan melalui bukti kesetaraan dalam video ini tapi ia
tidak sukar dan jika anda berminat anda boleh jumpa buktinya dalam bahan bertulis untuk pelajaran yang ada pautan dalam huraian video
kita dah bincangkan apa yang berlaku apabila pengukuran umum dilakukan ke atas sistem dalam keadaan tertentu
sekurang-kurangnya untuk kes pengukuran memusnah seterusnya kita akan bincangkan pengukuran separa iaitu hanya
satu bahagian sistem kompaun yang diukur untuk tepat katakan kita ada sepasang sistem XZ yang
bersama-sama berada dalam keadaan yang diterangkan oleh matriks ketumpatan rho dan pengukuran yang diterangkan oleh koleksi matriks semi-definitif positif yang berjumlah kepada
identiti dilakukan ke atas sistem X sahaja ini secara semula jadinya menghasilkan
hasil pengukuran dan kerana kita bercakap tentang pengukuran memusnah kita boleh bayangkan bahawa proses pengukuran memusnahkan sistem
X tapi kita masih ada sistem Z untuk dibimbangkan dan kita perlu faham bagaimana pengukuran X mempengaruhi
keadaan Z pertama jom kita bincangkan kebarangkalian hasil
kerana kita bercakap tentang pengukuran sistem X sahaja kebarangkalian untuk hasil berbeza
muncul hanya bergantung pada keadaan X secara berasingan iaitu ia hanya bergantung pada
keadaan terkurang X khususnya kebarangkalian untuk hasil tertentu a muncul diberikan oleh
formula yang sama dari sebelumnya iaitu surih PA darab keadaan terkurang X yang kita tandakan dengan rho
subx keadaan rho subx diperoleh dari rho dengan mengesan keluar Z jadi kita boleh buat
penggantian itu dan walaupun mungkin tidak jelas serta merta soalan yang kita dapat boleh ditulis secara alternatif seperti yang
ditunjukkan di skrin ia ialah surih PA ditensor dengan matriks identiti pada sistem Z darab
rho kini itu adalah kesamaan yang pasti berbaloi untuk ambil sedikit masa untuk sahkan ia bersifat intuitif kita tidak buat
apa-apa pun kepada Z jadi masuk akal bahawa identiti pada Z sepatutnya muncul seperti ini tapi ia juga boleh disahkan
secara algebra dan saya serahkan itu kepada anda bersama cadangan untuk pertama pertimbangkan kes di mana rho ialah hasil tensor dua matriks kemudian
gunakan kelinearan untuk simpulkan bahawa ia mesti berfungsi untuk semua rho dan saya juga akan katakan bahawa ia tidak bergantung pada fakta bahawa PA
ialah semi-definitif positif atau bahawa rho ialah matriks ketumpatan ini ialah kesamaan yang akan berfungsi untuk mana-mana pilihan
matriks sebagai ganti PA dan rho selagi ia mempunyai dimensi yang betul untuk menjadikan ungkapan itu masuk
akal dan sekarang jom kita lihat bagaimana keadaan Z dipengaruhi oleh pengukuran dan pendekatan semula jadi menurut
pandangan saya ialah dengan memikirkan pengukuran sebagai saluran ini adalah saluran yang kita kaitkan dengan pengukuran kita dan kita
fikirkan ini sebagai saluran dari sistem X ke sistem y baru yang keadaan klasiknya sepadan dengan hasil pengukuran jadi dalam formula ini
Sigma mewakili keadaan sistem X sahaja jika kita gunakan saluran ini ke atas
sistem X semasa pasangan XZ berada dalam keadaan rho maka kita akan mendapat matriks ketumpatan yang ada di sini
ambil masa yang anda perlukan untuk sahkan ini dan sekali lagi cadangan saya ialah pertama pertimbangkan kes di mana rho adalah hasil tensor
dua matriks kemudian gunakan kelinearan sekarang kita lihat jenis keadaan ini
di mana sistem pertama adalah klasik dan sistem kedua adalah kuantum sebagai contoh dalam pelajaran
matriks ketumpatan setiap a berlaku dengan sesetengah kebarangkalian dan itu adalah surih faktor tensor kedua jadi anda boleh fikirkan
tentang faktor tensor kedua ini sebagai matriks ketumpatan yang didarab dengan kebarangkalian jadi untuk mendapatkan keadaan
Z dengan syarat mendapat hasil pengukuran a tertentu kita cukup bahagikan keluar kebarangkalian atau dalam erti kata lain kita
normalisasikan faktor tensor kedua dengan membahagikannya dengan surhnya sendiri jadi secara ringkasnya jika kita lakukan
pengukuran ke atas X semasa pasangan XZ berada dalam keadaan rho inilah yang berlaku pertama setiap hasil a muncul
dengan kebarangkalian sama dengan surih PA ditensor dengan identiti darab rho dan kedua dengan syarat mendapat
WEBVTT
hasil pengukuran a tertentu keadaan Z diberikan oleh ungkapan yang ditunjukkan di skrin yang merupakan apa yang kita dapat
dengan menormalisasikan Matriks yang baru kita lihat sebentar tadi dan itu sama dengan membahagi matriks dengan kebarangkalian
untuk a muncul saya perlu sebut bahawa ini hanya masuk akal jika kebarangkaliannya bukan sifar kerana jika tidak kita sedang
membahagi dengan sifar tapi itu okey kerana kita tidak perlu ambil kisah tentang perkara yang tidak berlaku dalam bahagian ini
dalam pelajaran kita akan bincangkan teorem mudah tapi asas tentang pengukuran yang dikenali sebagai teorem Naimark
secara ringkasnya apa yang dikatakannya ialah mana-mana pengukuran boleh dilaksanakan seperti yang ditunjukkan oleh rajah di skrin
dalam kata-kata pengukuran Umum tertentu ke atas sistem X boleh dilaksanakan dengan cara berikut
kita terlebih dahulu memperkenalkan sistem ruang kerja y yang dimulakan di mana keadaan klasiknya adalah kemungkinan hasil pengukuran yang kita andaikan
bernombor 0 hingga n tolak satu kemudian operasi unitari U dilakukan ke atas pasangan
YX dan kemudian pengukuran asas piawai dilakukan ke atas y jadi segala-galanya pada dasarnya sudah ditetapkan
kecuali untuk pilihan U dan apa yang dikatakan teorem ialah ia memang mungkin untuk memilih operasi unitari ini
U supaya kebarangkalian untuk hasil-hasil berbeza sentiasa bersesuaian dengan pengukuran Umum yang diberikan
sekarang jom kita lihat bagaimana teorem Naimark dibuktikan dan ia tidak sukar kita hanya perlu buat pilihan yang baik untuk
operasi unitari U dan sahkan ia berfungsi tapi pertama kita perlukan fakta asas
dari Teori Matriks iaitu untuk mana-mana Matriks semi-definitif positif P sentiasa ada matriks semi-definitif positif yang unik
Q supaya Q kuasa dua sama dengan P secara umum mungkin ada banyak matriks yang dikuasaduakan memberi kita P tapi
sentiasa hanya satu yang semi-definitif positif notasi yang kita gunakan untuk menandakan Matriks ini ialah punca kuasa dua
p dan begitulah juga cara kita merujuknya dalam kata-kata jika anda ingin kira punca kuasa dua P untuk sesetengah
Matriks semi-definitif positif P ngomong-ngomong anda boleh buat itu dengan terlebih dahulu kira penguraian spektral p kemudian
gantikan setiap nilai eigen dengan punca kuasa duanya dan biarkan vektor-vektor eigen tidak berubah nilai-nilai eigen semuanya tidak
negatif jadi ini masuk akal dan agak mudah untuk lihat bahawa Matriks yang kita dapat memang semi-definitif positif
dan dikuasaduakan kepada P fakta bahawa ia Unik adalah perkara berbeza ia tidak sukar untuk
buktikan menggunakan beberapa fakta asas tentang matriks tapi ia agak tidak relevan dengan pelajaran dan kita akan ambil bahagian itu
sebagai diberikan dan sekarang kita ada konsep itu dalam tangan agak mudah untuk tentukan
operasi unitari U yang berfungsi mana-mana Matriks unitari yang sepadan dengan corak yang ditunjukkan di skrin akan
berfungsi n lajur pertama dengan mengandaikan X mempunyai n keadaan klasik seperti sebelumnya diperoleh dengan menghimpun punca kuasa dua
matriks-matriks yang menerangkan pengukuran di atas satu sama lain dan lajur-lajur selebihnya boleh berapa sahaja yang kita
mahu ia tidak membuat sebarang perbezaan selagi keseluruhan Matriks itu unitari
dan ngomong-ngomong jika anda nampak persamaan dengan hubungan antara representasi Kraus dan Stein spring bagi saluran itu bukan kebetulan dan
sebenarnya apa yang kita ada di sini pada dasarnya adalah kes khas itu di mana matriks-matriks cross kita semuanya kebetulan semi-definitif positif
jadi ada dua perkara yang perlu kita semak yang pertama ialah pilihan u ini sebenarnya berfungsi dan yang
kedua ialah ia mungkin untuk pilih lajur-lajur yang tidak dinyatakan dengan cara yang menjadikan u unitari jadi jom mulakan dengan yang pertama
ini adalah keadaan yang kita mulakan dengannya sistem bawah Y dimulakan ke keadaan sifar sementara sistem atas
bermula dalam keadaan rho dan kemudian kita jalankan U yang bermaksud kita konjugatkan dengan
U kita boleh tuliskan semuanya dalam sebutan matriks blok seperti yang ditunjukkan di skrin kita ada U di sebelah kiri U dagger di
kanan dan ket sifar bra sifar ditensor dengan rho di tengah yang mengambil bentuk yang ada di sini di mana kita ada rho di
penjuru kiri atas dan sifar di mana-mana dan jika anda fikirkan hasil darab ini seketika adalah jelas bahawa
entri-entri yang tidak dinyatakan bagi u tidak penting sama sekali kerana ia sentiasa didarab dengan entri-entri sifar daripada
Matriks di tengah dan jika kita buat pengiraan pendaraban apa yang kita dapat ialah
Matriks yang ditunjukkan di sini diterangkan sebagai matriks blok atau secara alternatif kita boleh nyatakannya menggunakan notasi ket langsung
seperti ini itu sebenarnya bentuk yang lebih mudah untuk kita jadi jom tumpukan perhatian pada
ungkapan ini dan demi kemudahan jom berikan Matriks ini yang merupakan matriks ketumpatan nama
Sigma langkah terakhir ialah pengukuran asas piawai ke atas y jadi jom kita kira keadaan terkurang dalam y dan
itu mudah memandangkan ungkapan yang kita ada kita cukup surih keluar X yang sepadan dengan faktor tensor kedua
jadi kebarangkalian untuk sebarang hasil a muncul ialah entri pepenjuru yang sepadan dengan a kita boleh tulis
itu seperti ini dan ia sama dengan surih punca kuasa dua PA darab rho darab punca kuasa dua
PA dan dengan sifat kitaran surih kita dapat surih PA darab rho
yang merupakan apa yang kita harapkan jadi kebarangkalian untuk hasil-hasil berbeza muncul adalah betul ia sentiasa bersesuaian
dengan pengukuran asal yang kita mulakan dengannya perkara kedua yang perlu kita semak
ialah bahawa ia mungkin untuk isi lajur-lajur yang tidak dinyatakan bagi U dengan cara yang menjadikannya
unitari ini mengikut dari fakta bahawa n lajur pertama yang merupakan yang dibentuk oleh punca kuasa dua matriks-matriks yang menerangkan
pengukuran itu adalah ortonormal dan itu boleh disemak agak secara langsung butiran yang relevan ada di sini
di skrin jadi jedakan video dan ambil beberapa minit untuk fikirkan itu jika anda mahu tapi seperti yang saya cadangkan sebelumnya
ia sebenarnya adalah kes khas sesuatu yang kita temui dalam pelajaran sebelumnya dan itulah
buktinyalah setakat ini dalam pelajaran kita menumpukan perhatian kita pada pengukuran memusnah yang bermaksud tiada spesifikasi
keadaan kuantum selepas pengukuran bagi sistem yang diukur untuk pengukuran tidak-memusnah pula sebaliknya ada
bukan sahaja hasil pengukuran klasik tapi juga keadaan kuantum selepas pengukuran bagi sistem yang diukur dan seperti
yang akan kita lihat ada hubungan semula jadi dengan teorem Naimark sebenarnya ada beberapa cara berbeza untuk merumuskan pengukuran tidak-memusnah
dalam istilah matematik tapi kita akan mulakan dengan satu perumusan yang pada dasarnya datang terus dari teorem Naimark
pertimbangkan pengukuran umum iaitu pengukuran memusnah yang diterangkan oleh koleksi matriks semi-definitif positif
p 0 hingga PN tolak satu yang berjumlah kepada identiti kita kemudiannya boleh ubah ini
WEBVTT
pengukuran menjadi pengukuran tidak-memusnah hanya dengan mempertimbangkan pelaksanaan pengukuran ini yang kita bincangkan dalam konteks teorem Naimark
kita perkenalkan sistem y baru berinteraksi dengannya melalui X melalui operasi unitari U dan kemudian jalankan pengukuran asas piawai
ke atas y jadi sistem X masih ada dan kita boleh pertimbangkan
keadaannya dan berdasarkan analisis yang kita lalui kita boleh tentukan bahawa keadaan selepas pengukuran bagi X dengan syarat
mendapat hasil pengukuran a tertentu diberikan oleh matriks ketumpatan yang kelihatan seperti
ini dalam kata-kata kita konjugatkan dengan punca kuasa dua matriks pengukuran yang sepadan kemudian
normalisasikan cara lain untuk merumuskan pengukuran tidak-memusnah yang lebih Umum ialah dalam sebutan matriks cross
bagi saluran dan ini ialah takrifan pengukuran yang anda akan jumpa dalam buku teks terkenal oleh Nielsen dan
Chuang misalnya andaikan bahawa m0 hingga m m tolak satu adalah matriks kuasa dua yang memenuhi
persamaan yang ditunjukkan di skrin iaitu kita boleh fikirkan tentang matriks-matriks ini sebagai matriks cross yang menerangkan
saluran sebenarnya matriks-matriks ini memang menerangkan saluran tapi ia juga menerangkan pengukuran tidak-memusnah
dan cara kerjanya apabila sistem dalam keadaan rho tertentu diukur ialah pertama kebarangkalian hasil diberikan oleh
persamaan yang ditunjukkan di skrin setiap hasil muncul dengan kebarangkalian sama dengan surih ma darab
rho darab ma dagger dan dengan syarat hasil a muncul keadaan sistem yang diukur
kelihatan seperti ini pengukuran tidak-memusnah jenis ini boleh dilaksanakan dengan
cara yang serupa dengan apa yang kita ada untuk teorem Naimark dan saya serahkan itu kepada anda untuk fikirkan jika anda
mahu ia mungkin untuk menggeneralisasikan konsep pengukuran tidak-memusnah lebih jauh dari ini misalnya
ada konsep apa yang dipanggil instrumen Kuantum yang kadang-kadang cukup berguna tapi saya tidak akan liputi itu dalam
video ini dalam bahagian terakhir pelajaran saya akan sebutkan secara ringkas dua tugas yang berkaitan dengan pengukuran iaitu Diskriminasi Keadaan Kuantum dan Tomografi Keadaan Kuantum
ada banyak yang boleh dikatakan tentang kedua-dua konsep ini dan kita hanya akan menggores
permukaan jadi jom mulakan dengan menjelaskan apa yang dimaksudkan oleh istilah-istilah ini dan bagaimana ia berbeza
pertama ialah diskriminasi keadaan kuantum idea di sini ialah kita ada koleksi keadaan kuantum yang diketahui
bagi sesetengah sistem berserta kebarangkalian yang berkaitan dengan keadaan-keadaan ini jadi untuk tepat katakan kita andaikan
bahawa rho 0 hingga rho M tolak satu adalah matriks ketumpatan yang mewakili keadaan kuantum yang mungkin bagi sistem X dan p 0
hingga PN tolak satu adalah kebarangkalian yang berkaitan dengan keadaan-keadaan ini jadi jika kita kumpulkan kebarangkalian ke dalam satu
vektor kita dapat vektor kebarangkalian cara ringkas untuk menyatakannya ngomong-ngomong ialah kita ada ensembel keadaan kuantum
dan sekarang cara abstrak kita boleh fikirkan tentang Diskriminasi Keadaan Kuantum sebagai tugas atau sebagai masalah
ialah pertama nombor antara sifar dan N tolak satu dipilih secara rawak mengikut kebarangkalian sistem X kemudian
disediakan dalam keadaan yang sepadan dengan nombor yang dipilih secara rawak dan matlamatnya ialah untuk tentukan melalui
pengukuran X nombor mana yang dipilih jadi kita ada bilangan terhad
alternatif berserta prior dan matlamatnya ialah untuk tentukan alternatif mana yang sebenarnya berlaku untuk sesetengah pilihan keadaan dan
kebarangkalian ini mungkin mudah dan untuk yang lain mungkin tidak dapat melakukan ini tanpa sesetengah peluang untuk membuat kesilapan
dan ada pelbagai soalan khusus yang boleh kita tanya seperti apa kebarangkalian minimum untuk membuat kesilapan
dan bagaimana rupanya pengukuran yang mencapai kebarangkalian kesilapan minimum ini Tomografi Keadaan Kuantum pula
berbeza di sini kita ada keadaan Kuantum yang tidak diketahui bagi sebuah sistem jadi biasanya
tiada prior atau sebarang maklumat tentang kemungkinan alternatif kali ini bagaimanapun bukan satu salinan keadaan yang dibuat
tersedia tapi sebaliknya banyak salinan bebas yang disediakan yang bermaksud bahawa untuk sesetengah nombor yang mungkin besar
n kita ada n sistem yang sama X1 hingga xn yang masing-masing secara bebas disediakan dalam keadaan
rho dan kali ini matlamatnya ialah untuk mencari penghampiran kepada Keadaan Kuantum yang tidak diketahui ini sebagai matriks ketumpatan dengan mengukur
sistem-sistem jadi secara ringkasnya dalam Diskriminasi Keadaan Kuantum kita ada satu salinan
keadaan dan kita cuba membezakan antara bilangan terhad alternatif yang diketahui dan dalam Tomografi Keadaan Kuantum kita ada banyak salinan bebas
daripada Keadaan Kuantum yang tidak diketahui dan matlamatnya ialah untuk mencari penerangan keadaan itu atau sekurang-kurangnya penghampiran yang berpatutan
Diskriminasi keadaan kuantum adalah menarik kerana ia mengabstrakkan jenis situasi yang biasa timbul dalam
pengiraan dan kriptografi misalnya di mana satu alternatif daripada set kemungkinan terhad telah berlaku dan kita atau orang lain cuba
untuk cari tahu yang mana satunya dengan mengukur sistem Kuantum kes paling mudah yang tidak remeh ialah
apabila hanya ada dua alternatif iaitu m sama dengan dua jadi tugasnya ialah untuk membezakan antara sepasang
keadaan kes ini rupanya merupakan masalah yang sepenuhnya dapat diselesaikan dengan mengandaikan matlamatnya ialah untuk meminimumkan
peluang diskriminasi yang salah ada pilihan optimum untuk pengukuran dan ia kerap dipanggil
pengukuran Holevo ia adalah pengukuran projektif sebenarnya dan ia boleh diterangkan seperti
berikut pertama kita pertimbangkan perbezaan berwajaran antara dua alternatif iaitu p 0 darab rho 0 tolak P1 darab rho satu
jadi kita mendarab kebarangkalian untuk menarik setiap daripada dua keadaan ini ke keadaan itu sendiri dan kita mengambil
perbezaannya itu adalah matriks Hermitian kerana ia sama dengan konjugat transposnya sendiri jadi ia mempunyai penguraian spektral
dan kita tahu khususnya bahawa nilai-nilai eigennya semuanya nombor nyata jadi katakan kita ada
penguraian spektral yang ditulis dalam bentuk yang ditunjukkan di skrin apa yang kita buat seterusnya ialah mengumpulkan
nilai-nilai eigen ke dalam dua set di mana semua nilai eigen positif berada dalam satu set dan semua nilai eigen negatif berada dalam
yang lain untuk tepat katakan S0 sebagai set semua indeks k di mana nilai eigen Lambda K yang sepadan adalah
tidak negatif dan biarkan S1 sebagai indeks-indeks selebihnya yang merupakan yang sepadan dengan nilai eigen negatif
sebenarnya tidak penting set mana yang mengandungi indeks yang sepadan dengan sebarang nilai eigen sifar di sini kita sedang membuat
pilihan sewenang-wenangnya untuk memasukkan yang minus sifar tapi tidak akan membuat sebarang perbezaan jika sebahagian atau kesemuanya dimasukkan dalam S1 sebaliknya yang benar-benar penting ialah
bahawa kita memisahkan nilai-nilai eigen positif dan negatif dan akhirnya kita takrifkan dua unjuran Pi
0 dan Pi 1 seperti yang ditunjukkan di skrin dalam kata-kata Pi 0 ialah unjuran ke atas
WEBVTT
subruang yang direntangi oleh vektor-vektor eigen yang sepadan dengan nilai-nilai eigen tidak negatif dan Pi 1 ialah unjuran ke atas ruang
yang direntangi oleh vektor-vektor eigen yang sepadan dengan nilai-nilai eigen negatif ini memang unjuran dan
jika kita tambahkan ia bersama kita dapat matriks identiti kerana vektor-vektor eigen s 0 hingga s N tolak satu membentuk
asas ortonormal jika pengukuran ini dilakukan dalam situasi yang ada iaitu
keadaan yang diukur ialah rho 0 dengan kebarangkalian p 0 dan rho satu dengan kebarangkalian P1 maka rupanya
kebarangkalian pengenalan yang betul mempunyai formula yang cukup mudah dalam sebutan nilai-nilai eigen Lambda 0 hingga Lambda n tolak
satu saya tidak akan melalui butiran pengiraan dalam video ini anda boleh rujuk kandungan bertulis yang ada pautan dalam huraian video jika anda
berminat atau cuba yakinkan diri anda bahawa formula ini memang betul kita juga boleh nyatakan
kebarangkalian ini menggunakan Norma matriks yang biasanya dipanggil Norma surih ia adalah notasi yang serupa dengan norma Euclidean untuk vektor
kecuali kita ada subskrip satu untuk menunjukkan bahawa ia adalah Norma surih Norma surih sangat penting dan ia
sangat kerap ditemui dalam Pengiraan Kuantum tapi saya tidak akan kata banyak lebih tentangnya dalam pelajaran ini satu cara untuk
mentakrifkannya untuk matriks Hermitian ialah ia adalah jumlah nilai mutlak bagi nilai-nilai eigen jadi anda boleh fikirkan
tentang kesamaan kedua ini sebagai mengikut terus dari takrifan itu Norma surih juga boleh
ditakrifkan dengan cara lain yang lebih umum dan kita akan jumpa norma surih lagi dalam pelajaran seterusnya ini sebenarnya
adalah yang terbaik yang boleh anda buat pengukuran ini adalah optimum dengan andaian matlamat anda ialah untuk memaksimumkan peluang teka
yang betul fakta itu kadang-kadang dipanggil teorem Helstrom-Holevo dan ia kadang-kadang hanya dipanggil teorem
Helstrom jadi anda tidak boleh kalahkan pengukuran ini dari segi kebarangkalian ketepatan dan ia bagus kerana
ada resipi mudah untuk pengukuran itu sendiri dan formula tepat untuk kebarangkalian ketepatan dalam sebutan surih
Norma Norma surih kerap digunakan sebagai cara untuk mengukur perbezaan yang dapat diperhatikan antara matriks ketumpatan untuk
sebab inilah dan apabila orang merujuk kepada jarak surih antara keadaan mereka biasanya merujuk kepada
setengah kali Norma surih perbezaan antara dua matriks ketumpatan yang di sini sepadan dengan kes di mana p 0 dan P1 kedua-duanya 1/2 yang
merupakan kes semula jadi untuk dipertimbangkan Diskriminasi Keadaan Kuantum untuk dua keadaan diselesaikan secara optimum oleh
pengukuran Helstrom untuk mana kita ada resipi mudah dan formula mudah untuk kebarangkalian
ketepatan jadi apa yang berlaku apabila kita ingin membezakan antara tiga atau lebih keadaan dalam kes ini kita tidak ada
formula secara umum untuk pilihan optimum pengukuran atau ungkapan mudah untuk kebarangkalian maksimum
ketepatan namun begitu adalah mungkin untuk mencari penghampiran yang baik kepada pengukuran optimum dengan bantuan komputer
dan khususnya itu boleh dilakukan menggunakan teknik pengoptimuman yang sangat menakjubkan dan berkuasa yang dikenali sebagai pengaturcaraan semi-definitif tapi ia bukan
sesuatu yang boleh anda laksanakan secara munasabah menggunakan pensel dan sekeping kertas misalnya sebaliknya jika seseorang
memberi anda penerangan tentang pengukuran dan mendakwa kepada anda bahawa pengukuran ini adalah optimum untuk tugas Diskriminasi Keadaan Kuantum maka ia
sebenarnya sangat mudah untuk sama ada sahkan atau batalkan dakwaan itu dan itu boleh dilakukan menggunakan apa yang dipanggil syarat Holevo-Yuen-
Kennedy-Lax saya tidak akan jelaskan apa ia dalam video ini tapi ia adalah syarat yang mudah dan agak keren
bahawa ini mungkin ini adalah contoh yang menyambung kembali kepada keadaan-keadaan tetrahedron
yang kita lihat lebih awal dalam pelajaran katakan kita diberi salah satu daripada empat keadaan ini yang dipilih secara rawak dengan
kebarangkalian satu perempat untuk masing-masing dan matlamat kita ialah untuk tentukan keadaan mana yang kita diberi ia mungkin tidak mengejutkan tapi
pilihan terbaik yang boleh anda buat untuk pengukuran untuk melakukan ini ialah pengukuran tetrahedron anda tidak selalu boleh buat
sesuatu seperti ini untuk koleksi keadaan tulen yang sewenang-wenangnya tapi kerana simetri yang terlibat di sini ini memang
berfungsi dan kita sebenarnya mendapat pengukuran yang sah dan melalui syarat Holevo-Yuen-Kennedy-Lax yang saya sebut
beberapa saat lalu rupanya agak mudah untuk buktikan bahawa ini memang pilihan optimum
pengukuran khususnya apa yang berlaku di sini ialah pengukuran sentiasa betul dengan kebarangkalian 1/2 yang bukan
teruk kerana ada empat alternatif jadi kebarangkalian teka yang betul adalah dua kali lebih baik daripada teka rawak dan ia
kebetulan adalah yang terbaik yang boleh anda buat untuk keadaan-keadaan ini sekarang saya akan cakap sedikit lebih tentang Tomografi Keadaan Kuantum
WEBVTT
di mana kita ada banyak salinan bebas daripada Keadaan Kuantum yang tidak diketahui dan matlamatnya ialah untuk mencari penghampiran matriks ketumpatan yang menerangkan
keadaan itu sebenarnya ada beberapa varian berbeza bagi masalah ini yang bergantung pada andaian anda dan
khususnya pada jenis pengukuran yang anda benarkan misalnya kita boleh menuntut bahawa setiap sistem diukur secara individu dan
hasilnya digabungkan entah bagaimana untuk sampai kepada penerangan matriks ketumpatan atau kita boleh benarkan semua
sistem diukur bersama sebagai sistem kompaun tunggal yang jauh lebih baik secara teorinya tapi ia juga jauh lebih
menuntut dari segi teknologi selain pilihan yang dibuat untuk pengukuran ada
juga pertimbangan penting iaitu cara untuk merekonstruksi penerangan matriks ketumpatan daripada data yang anda dapat
dari pengukuran saya tidak akan masuk ke butiran tentang ini maksud saya hanyalah untuk mencadangkan
bahawa Tomografi Keadaan Kuantum sebenarnya lebih merupakan konsep payung yang mempunyai banyak varian berbeza berbanding menjadi
prosedur tunggal ada banyak penyelidikan yang telah dilakukan tentang masalah ini termasuk beberapa hasil
terobosan yang agak baru-baru ini yang menghubungkan bilangan salinan n dengan ketepatan penghampiran yang boleh diperoleh dan ia terus menjadi
kawasan penyelidikan yang menarik dan aktif untuk mengakhiri pelajaran jom kita lihat Tomografi Keadaan Kuantum
untuk qubit dan bagaimana kita boleh melakukannya jadi katakan rho adalah matriks ketumpatan yang mewakili keadaan
satu qubit dan X1 hingga xn adalah qubit yang semuanya telah disediakan secara bebas dalam keadaan rho dan untuk
tujuan perbincangan ini katakan n adalah besar apa yang boleh kita buat ialah membahagikan
sistem-sistem kepada tiga timbunan yang lebih kurang sama dan untuk timbunan pertama kita akan jalankan pengukuran berkenaan dengan asas plus
tolak untuk setiap hasil yang sepadan dengan plus kita akan beri skor tambah satu dan untuk setiap
hasil yang sepadan dengan tolak kita akan beri skor tolak satu cara yang lebih ringkas untuk menerangkan pengukuran ini
ialah bahawa ia adalah pengukuran Pauli X kerana keadaan-keadaan plus dan tolak ialah vektor-vektor eigen matriks Pauli X dan
nilai-nilai eigen yang sepadan ialah tambah satu dan tolak satu dan sebenarnya itu juga cara yang jauh lebih biasa untuk menerangkannya dan
memang nilai yang dijangkakan untuk skor itu sama dengan surih Sigma x darab rho kini kita tidak semestinya tahu apa
nilai yang dijangkakan ini tapi jika kita puratakan skor yang kita peroleh dalam banyak ulangan kita agak mungkin untuk mendapat
penghampiran yang berpatutan kepada nilai yang dijangkakan ini dengan hukum nombor besar dan ada beberapa batasan statistik yang terkenal yang boleh kita gunakan
terhadap ini jika kita mahu lebih kuantitatif tentang pernyataan itu kita buat sesuatu yang serupa dengan Sigma y pada satu pertiga kedua daripada
sistem-sistem satu-satunya perkara yang berubah di sini ialah kita menggunakan keadaan-keadaan plus i dan tolak i yang merupakan vektor-vektor eigen Sigma
Y dan begitu juga untuk Sigma Z yang vektor-vektor asas piawainya adalah vektor-vektor eigen
dan kemudiannya akhirnya kita boleh gunakan formula yang ditunjukkan di skrin yang memberitahu kita apakah pekali-pekalinya
jika rho ditulis sebagai gabungan linear matriks-matriks Pauli dan dengan menggantikan penghampiran kita untuk pekali-pekali ini
dan mungkin menyesuaikannya sedikit untuk memastikan kita mendapat Matriks semi-definitif positif kita mendapat penghampiran kepada
rho tentunya ada butiran yang belum saya masuki seperti ketepatan penghampiran dan tahap
keyakinan yang boleh kita harapkan tapi semoga itu memberi anda gambaran asas tentang satu cara tomografi boleh dilakukan ke atas
qubit ia juga mungkin untuk melakukan tomografi qubit menggunakan pengukuran tetrahedron dan sebenarnya ini rupanya
adalah agak mudah dan elegan sekurang-kurangnya dalam istilah matematik apa yang boleh kita buat ialah jalankan hanya
pengukuran tunggal ini sahaja ke atas semua salinan bebas Keadaan Kuantum yang tidak diketahui kita dan dengan menggunakan
formula luar biasa yang ditunjukkan di sini kita boleh hasilkan penghampiran keadaan kita dengan menganggarkan surih PK darab
rho untuk setiap K mengikut pecahan kali hasil pengukuran yang sepadan muncul sekali lagi ini hanya berfungsi kerana
simetri sempurna yang kita ada di antara keempat-empat keadaan ini dan sebenarnya ada beberapa masalah yang belum diselesaikan yang sangat menakjubkan yang berkaitan dengan generalisasi
pendekatan ini kepada sistem yang lebih besar dan itu tempat yang baik untuk berhenti pelajaran terima kasih kerana menonton dan
saya harap anda akan ikut saya untuk pelajaran seterusnya yang berkaitan dengan penulenan dan kesetiaan selamat tinggal buat masa ini